[Music]
so hi I'm Mike Lauren I'm on the Android
team I manage the system UI framework
and UI toolkit team share we're going to
be talking today in a lot of detail
about some big changes to how we
recommend that you build Android
applications but before we go into a lot
of the details I thought it'd be helpful
to step back a bit and frame the
discussion by talking about where we
came from and where we're going so let's
do that
so to start Android has always been
based on some strong principles not
surprisingly those were best expressed
by Dianne Hackborn she's the one who
actually architected most of the android
framework
she would have post about this a few
months back and I have some excerpts
from that here if you look at our core
primitive activity broadcast receiver
service content provider you might
reasonably think that those constitute
and application framework but that's not
the right way to think about it these
classes are actually contracts between
the application and the operating system
they represent the minimal amount of
information necessary so the OS knows
what's going on inside your app so we
can manage it properly so as an example
if your app is running in the background
but it's also exposing data to another
application through a content provider
the OS needs to know that and we need to
know that so we don't accidentally kill
you the content provider is a mechanism
that tells us that so that we can keep
you alive so we think of these core
classes as really being like the
fundamental laws of physics for Android
hence the illustration that is the cover
of the manuscript where Isaac Newton
first presented the basic laws of motion
now fundamental laws are a good thing I
use the shorthand when talking about
this I say
Android has good bones even though
people look at me funny after I say that
but what I mean by that is that Android
is based on a small stable cohesive
set of core primitives and that allows a
common programming model across a really
incredibly diverse range of devices from
wearables to phones to tablets to TVs
the cars and more this model also gives
application developers the freedom to
choose whatever framework they want
inside their application for their
internal framework so that means that we
on the a droid team don't have to get
involved in debates about whether MVC is
better than MVP or whether MVP is better
than the MVP p.m. you guys can pick
whatever makes sense to you now that's a
pretty good story if you are in the
operating system business like say me
but if you're in the app development
business like say all of you that's
really only chapter one of the story and
the reason for that is because while
strong fundamentals and freedom of
choice are good things we know that in
your day to day jobs and we know this
because you told us you want more from
us so I'm going to abuse my analogy a
bit here we can all appreciate the
simple elegance of Newton's laws of
motion but if your job is to land a
rover on Mars you don't want to come to
work each day and start with only F
equals MA and drive everything from
first principles so we've been talking
to developers both inside and outside of
Google and taking a hard look at the app
development experience and we've
realized a couple of things first there
are peaks and valleys some aspects of
app development are better served by our
API s and others for example we think
recyclerview is at the better end of
that spectrum
so with recyclerview we didn't say okay
we give you events and you can draw
stuff and in between you have a Turing
complete language so good luck with
everything else on the other hand maybe
activity and fragment life cycles belong
down in that dark shadowy place because
they're I think too much of it is indeed
left as an exercise for the reader and
you want to fix that
so as we thought about this we realized
the good solution has some key
properties first we have to solve the
right problems this is going to be a
sustained effort like sustained for us
on Android but for the first cut we want
to make sure that we're going after the
problems that every developer faces the
things that are hard to do right right
now again app life cycles is a really
good example if you don't get that right
in your app nothing is going to work on
top of that and that's true for your app
but that's also true for the frameworks
we're trying to build you have to get
that right before we can do anything
else second we have to play well with
others we know that you all have huge
investments in your existing code bases
and we can't create a model where the
first thing we say to you is throw all
that out and start over so we're trying
to create api's that you can adopt a
little bit of it at a time and also that
interoperate well with other libraries
or other frameworks third we want to be
more opinionated we're going to take a
stronger clear stance on how to Android
an app the right way East as we see it
now this is all still optional and if
you already have something that works
for you then great but developers are
telling us that they want more guidance
on how apps should be built and by the
way we're not changing any of the laws
of physics here we're just layering some
higher level constructs on top because
after all F is going to equal na whether
you believe it should or not next it
needs to scale we want solutions that
are industrial-strength and that will
scale to the real-world requirements of
real-world applications we don't want to
build something that's awesome for hello
world but then it's going to collapse
the first time it bumps into the messy
complexities of reality and finally
reach for this problem for making it
easier for you to write Android
applications the right way what we think
is the right way we want to use
libraries like support libera possible
rather than adding new api's to the
platform because that lets our solution
reach older versions of the OS as well
okay so that's the background on what
we're trying to accomplish and why we're
here now I'd like to introduce yeet
toolkit engineer extraordinaire and he's
going to walk you through what we
actually built
thank you okay hello everybody
so okay that was the back up what are we
shipping today the very first thing we
are shipping is an architecture guide on
developer.android.com/design as 'king us
for our opinion like how do we think
then an application should be built and
this is that guide so we believe that is
very good covers lots of application
cases but even if you have an
architecture that you are comfortable
with you can keep it but you can
probably learn something from this guide
second we are shipping a new set of
libraries that we call architecture
components these are more fundamental
components where you can build your
application on top the first thing is
lifecycle so this is the biggest
developer company we have life cycles
are hard life cycles are hard it's okay
we should solve this problem and the
first of all this is new set of
components second life cycle where
observables which we'll go in detail
later but this is basically kinks they
can do something based on the life cycle
third we are going to introduce a
lightweight view model which is all of
our effort to take out that code outside
of your activities and fragments and put
it somewhere else where you can easily
test it last but not least we are going
to introduce any object mapping library
for SQLite and all of this is available
for you today on maven calm
okay let's talk about life cycles so
what is what's hard about life cycles
why do we hear so many complains about
that let's go through an example assume
we have an activity where we want to
show the location of the device on the
screen so you'll dry something like this
you create a location listener you know
on create method you need to initialize
it with the context and you have a
callback that it calls whenever the
location changes and then you update the
I now if you have ever written an
Android application you know that this
code is never enough you also need to go
ahead and alright on start and then tell
it to start and overwrite on stop and
tell it to stop you always need to do
this babysitting for these components
but this is acceptable this is a simple
example this looks alright but then your
product manager comes and says oh you
know what we need to first check the
user settings before enabled like asking
for location then your developer says ok
sure
less they need to change I'm going to
change this method to first call the
futile tomatoes which probably makes the
web service call to check the user
settings and then if the user is
enrolled then we want to start the
location listener which looks like a
very simple change you will think this
would work but let's look at what
happens in that activity is life cycle
so activity was created we said okay
when start check if the users Studies is
enrolled the meanwhile user wants to
rotate the device which rotation means a
configuration change which means Android
is going to recreate that activity so in
also we knew about this and we said ok
location manager stop and then the new
activity came it also goes through the
same thing looks so right except do you
remember this call we make before the
little change and then it decides to
come back hey users enrolled and then
what we did we said ok that's part you
realize the bug we call start after
calling on stop which means our activity
will live forever we are going to
observe the location forever the battery
will drain we
have said users Leslie really this is a
situation right we want to get rid of
this not to put an end to this so we
said okay we know we need to acknowledge
against Mike mentioned we cannot change
the laws but we can make it easier to
deal with these things so we decided to
introduce a new interface called
lifecycle owner this is a thing with a
lifecycle is your activity is your
fragment or maybe you have your own UI
framework whatever the container you
have there is a lifecycle owner and we
have these lifecycle observers which are
the things that care about a lifecycle
like the location listener we have it
cares about the lifecycle it wants to
stop itself if the lifecycle is not
active so we said okay we will
acknowledge this and we have lifecycle
observers I'm going to go through our
activity now we make our activity extend
the lifecycle activity class this is the
set up pretty close until these
components reach 1.0 then everything in
support library will implement this
lifecycle owner interface inside the
reactivity when we initialize our
location listener we are going to tell
if this is the lifecycle you care about
and this all we will do rest is the same
it calls back the update the UI so how
can we change our location listener to
take advantage of this lifecycle or we
do the same thing for the user's force
as well ok so there's some boilerplate
code here to get the fields it doesn't
really matter but we have this enable
method which gets called if the user is
a role inside this enable method now we
want to start listening the location
only if the activity is started now you
can do this you can say what is my
current state which is amazing we had we
didn't have this API until now but now
you can circuit rather simple change but
we also get notified what if we get
enrolled when the activity was in the
back stake and user comes back to the
activity now we should actually start
the location manager for this we want to
observe that lifecycle
to do that we implies this interface
which allows us to write these methods
you can annotate a method saying that if
once that happens call this method and
the new components will take care of
calling it so if you are already enabled
now you start and onstop will disconnect
and last but not least if the activity
is destroyed there is nothing you want
to do with that activity so you can
unregister
so now you might be asking yourself well
you just move those on start on stop
methods from the activity into this
location manager like how come it is
simpler it's simply because those
methods live in the right place it's the
location manager which cares about the
life cycle so it should be able to do it
without the activity babysitting itself
like I'm sure if you look at your code
today your activity on start on stop
methods are like at least 20 30 lines of
code we want them to be zero lines of
code if we go back to activity I want to
point out something that look in
oncreate we initialize these components
and this only did we didn't overwrite we
didn't or stop on start we don't
overwrite any of those things because
the location manager is a life cycle
area confident now so the new constraint
we want to introduce a life cycle event
component is a component that can get a
life cycle and do the writing we can
take care of itself
so that your activity you can just
initialize it and forget about it you
know that it's not going to make you now
of course it was like more of moving the
complexity from activity to the location
manager and then it still needs to deal
with life cycle with it ok what do we
want is nice to be able to do that do
what we want more we want take very
convenient to handle this common case
it's very common that your activity or
fragment it observes some data and
whenever the data changes its runs the
refresh itself like it happens basically
almost every single UI and we want to
share resources across multiple
fragments or activities like the
location of the device is the same from
fragment to fragment if you have two
fragments why do you need to create two
listeners to listen the same
location has we created this new live
data cause let's look at that
so live data is a data holder it just
has some data like an observable but the
tricky thing about live data is that it
is life cycle away it understands about
life cycles because it understands our
life cycles it automatically manages
subscriptions so very similar to the
previous example if you are observing a
live data you don't need to ascribe
unsubscribe the right things will happen
in the right times so if that location
ELISA was a live data and a single time
because vocation singleton we could
write the code like this like get
business start observing and when you
observe you say this is my life cycle
this all you need to do before on
Android if you are observing something
singleton from an activity everyone will
give like - to the code reveal now you
can do this this is safe
nothing ever leaks so if you want to
change your location listener to use
this new API we get rid of all the
necessary things all we need the context
conduct but we say this is a live data
is alive date of a location then we get
these two new methods one of those
things on active which means you have an
active observer and the other one says
on inactive issues you don't have any
observers that are active now at this
point you are probably asking yourself
what is an active observer now we define
an active observer as an observer that's
in the started or resumed state which is
like an activity user is currently
seeing so here an observer in the back
stack there is no reason to call this
inactive like there is no reason to
update that activity because user will
never ever see what's going on there
so insider will connect method all we
need to do is whenever the system
location measure sends us a new location
we call set value on ourselves then the
line data knows which are the active
observers and delivers the data to those
observers or if one of the observers
like on the back stack and then becomes
visible again
live data takes care of sending the
latest data back to that observer and
then we can make our location listener
singleton because but we don't need
multiple instances so if you look at
live data it is a life cycle of eight
observables it is very simple status of
semantics doesn't matter how many
observers you have or what state they
are we merge all of it into one life
cycle and it doesn't have any activities
or fragments inside it but it works with
both of them and it's also going to test
live data because it's kind of Android
free and if you know about this like in
famous for net transaction exception we
guarantee that your observer will never
ever be cold in a state where you cannot
run a fragment transaction so this is
very specifically designed to work well
with your activities and fragments okay
let's think about configuration changes
now that example was easy because
location is global but most of the times
the data belongs to a UI so if we had an
activity where we show a user profile
and we implemented a web service that
can return the death either live data
which we can safely observe without
risking leaking over activity this one
looks nice you will never leave this
activity it will work very well except
what happens if the user rotates the
device let's look at the lifecycle graph
again so activity skated it says okay
fetch the user and then while you are
fetching the user user decides up I want
to rotate the phone and then the
activity is destroyed luckily we don't
leak it which is great but then the new
activities fast which makes the name
call now this is okay but not great what
do we want we want to actually retain
the data right we're already making that
request
why we make it so we want our graph to
look like this so if the live activity
comes we should be able to give it like
the same v-model
which is a new class called v-model
so we are introducing this new cost very
specific to this thing where you
put two data inside your activities into
the v-model
and make the activities data free so if
you want to change this activity we
create this new class it takes times the
v-model class whatever data we have
inside the activity we move it there and
in the v-model all we do is inside to
get user method if this is the first
goal get it from the web service
otherwise return the existing value now
super simple and inside the reactivity
we get rid of all that code we say get
the v-model providers of this so each
activity or fragment has a we model
provider that you can obtain and that we
model provided knows how to give you the
we model so when you call get my view
model the very first time you make this
call we will give you a new instance
when the rotated activity comes back
it's going to reconnect to the same D
model and then the rest of the code is
the same
so if you look at the lifecycle this how
it looks this is what we wanted the new
activities started it reconnects and
when the new activity is finished like
when we don't have anything to do with
that activity and then we go and tell
the model that it's not needed anymore
this is actually the only method in the
v-model class so it's very simple so if
you look at life cycles they hold the
data for the activity they survived
configuration changes they should never
ever reference views because they
outlive the activity so you cannot
reference back to the activity that's
why you use things like live data or
extra data binding observables to the
dead communication and this is what our
activity talks it always talks every
model now another big topic is
persistence now we need to write a good
responsive Android app you need to save
the data on disk
if you come to Android there's these
three major api's we have one of them is
content providers which is to talk
between processes it really has nothing
to do with persistence in reality the
other one is shared preferences which
says the detain XML so you can only put
very little data into that and the last
one is SQLite which is something maybe
shipping since Android one so you know
you need to use SQLite if you want to
say big data and so you go into the
developer Android comm this is the very
first saving your data slide this this
is so confusing this is very sad so is
it okay we want to make this that set
you want to make it happy so we look at
the example right so there's on top it
tries to say I want to select these
three columns with this constraint and I
want to order them like this it's
actually very very simple SQL query but
you need to write all this code plus
this code doesn't even show where you
define all those constants so what do we
really want we want to get rid of that
boilerplate free code when you're
writing Java if you make a typo in Java
it doesn't compile right we want the
same thing for a square
we still want to use SQLite because on
every single Android device is a proven
technology we know it works very well
but we want to compile time verification
so we don't want the boilerplate code we
want to compile time verification so is
it well we came up with room which is an
object mapping library for SQLite so if
you look at this query we said okay
let's move this query inside annotation
we like annotations and we have this
feed object which we want to save in the
database I want to put that query inside
an interface like you want to created
the feed dog doll stats or data access
object usually in database the best
practice to put your database access
into certain interfaces then we just
need to tell the room the Sirdar parent
is an entity and finally we had a
database class which says I have these
entities so you have multiple entities
and I have these data access objects as
if so them the soul you're right once
you write that you can get an
implementation of it from room is really
similar to how we use retrofit or dagger
you define the interfaces we provide the
implementation now once we know they
said oh well we can do these shortcut
methods like insert these items or
delete these items or update like a
bunch of shortcut methods you can place
multiple parameters as long as you can
read it and it makes sense you will
understand it but the most important
part of room is it understands your SQL
so the part like all those concepts I
mentioned we defined to get compile time
grantees room actually gives all of
these for free so when RUC's discrete is
okay you are receiving these three
columns from the stables where the title
looks like this keyword where is this
keyword coming from oh it's coming from
the function parameters makes us what
does it want to return it wants to
return a list of feeds and then room
goes and checks
does the columns return mesh the object
the user wants to return and once
they're equal stays okay
in generate this code you can never say
select star like you don't need to list
them room
I really really understand your query
you can never like join ten tables it
was to work but what if you made a typo
instead of saying three table you don't
feat now if this happens room is going
to give you an error at compile time so
it goes that and verifies your query
against the schema you have defined and
it tells you if something is wrong but
[Applause]
it's not the only thing it does so if
you say if your query is correct you
want to fetch ID and title this develops
query but you want to return it as a
string and the rule says while you are
returning two columns
but you only have one string that
doesn't make sense and it's going to
give you a compile time Aragon and if
they're very nicely to fix the same room
you can basically create any Java class
it doesn't need to be annotating there's
nothing special about that POJO and tell
the room to return it as long as
whatever query returns matches what you
wanted to return wrong we'll write the
code for you and also root which is very
important right if you have a query like
this now you're showing list of feeds
you always want to get notified when the
data changes and in room if you have to
do this all you have to do tell it tell
it to return a light data it will do it
for you because it knows your query it
knows what things affect it so it can
let you know if that code changes and
this is the part where all these
architectural components work well
together room already knows about live
data so your me models all you would
write is from the data is called this
query and this only will do whenever
they taste changes your UI will get any
updates and it only happens if the UI is
visible last but not least room also
suppose X Java to
[Applause]
okay if you look at the room in a
nutshell it writes the boilerplate code
for you it has full SQLite support you
can just write in SQLite there is no
builders it verifies your queries at
compile time it is centralizes best
practices which helps you with testing
migrations and it's also observable
out-of-the-box okay like pictures our
last topic today so we restarted right
and now you might be asking yourselves
what has changed in 2017 that you are
talking about architecture well actually
nothing has changed we've been talking
about this topic a like Adam Powell and
I gave a lot of talks on this topic
there is even a talk from 2010 which I
watch as a developer so this is a topic
we have been vocal about but what is
missing was a well-defined reference
architecture so it's what we are
shipping today if you go to the aprender
it come to the after session there is a
section about how to architect an
Android application
so I by the way this is a reference
guide this is not your religious book we
believe this is a very good way to write
applications but you don't need to
follow it line by line so I'm going to
briefly go through this architecture but
if you get lost don't worry we have all
of this documented on the aprender it's
come with sample applications so we
think that applications composed of four
main things
there's your eye controllers the Wii
models and upholstery and the data
sources let's look at these in detail
your eye controllers are your activities
fragments custom use they have very
simple tasks they observe the fields of
the v-model and update themselves and
they have one more responsibility
whenever user takes an action on the UI
they understand detection and call the V
models so experts whatever the user
wanted to do if you go to a we model the
model is the one which prepares the data
for the eye and horizontal this is very
data for the UI lives B model knows how
to get that beta
usually it has like live data if you're
using accelerators observable or data
binding observables it survives
configuration changes they survive where
we put the data into the V models and
it's also the gateway you can also
consider it as your UI controller only
ever talks to the v-model
to reach to the rest of the application
and I was the repository now the remodel
serves as a data store for your UI
control the right repository says is the
data store for all of your applications
so it's the complete data model for the
app and it provides this data with
simple API to the rest of the
application like you can never use the
repository where you pass a user ID and
it returns your live data of users how
it gets the data you don't care it's
preposterous job so how does it do that
it talks to the like fetching thinking
take a looking at database we're talking
to your retrofit back end is the
repositories job and last but not least
we have our data sources like your lace
API client you might be
using retrofit or you have SQLite
storage you might be using room or you
might be using that doesn't really
matter or you might be talking to other
content providers from other processes
these are things we call data sources
and we think that all of these layers
can discover each other to read
dependency injection system which will
recommend using dagger but we also
realize that understanding dependence
situation is not very trivial like it's
a more complex topic and sometimes might
be an overkill I can also use a service
locator if you feel more comfortable
with it so it's going to go through a
concrete example let's say we have a UI
that shows a user profile and we have
the data sources which like we save it
to database we also can get it from the
network how do we connect these two
things well we said you first need a
user repository use the repository knows
it should check the database it's not
there make a web request or meanwhile
also turn on the database it doesn't
matter how it does it but it knows how
to create a live date of a user or
unobservable doesn't know and then we
need to be mobile right because the data
for the UI lives in the v-model
so we create this profile v-model which
talks to the repository to get this
information and then the actual fragment
gets the data from the v-model so that
if the fragment comes back the light
data will be there in the profile
remodel but if the fragment disappears
completely we will get rid of the
remodel and the data can be garbage
collected
now all this abstraction we made if you
notice every single component only talks
to the one right below it which is how
to scale your application it also is a
great side benefit which is called
testing your testing right
so let's say you want to test your UI
now people say UI testing is hard UI
testing is yes is harder but it's
usually hard because you put all of your
code into that activity now we said put
most of it into the remodeled and united
the UI only talks to the v-model
so you can get rid of the other two you
only need to create a fake me model to
test your UID testing your you become
super super easy with espresso and we
have a sample app on github that you can
check how we test the UI and the same
thing is valid for remodels if you want
to test the v-model
you know it only talks to the
repositories you replace it with a mock
repository and it works and you can you
will test your remodels on your host
machine on JVM and last but not least
you can test the repository the same way
you just mock the data sources you can
either test your repositories SJ in a
test now I know these days being out of
information we have two sessions
tomorrow and also documentation but now
I want to call our product major Lucas
to talk about what to do next
like you said we just covered a lot of
ground and actually we glossed over a
lot of detail while we did that but
luckily you don't have to remember
everything that you just heard we have a
lot of material for you to check out at
developer.android.com slash arch and
that link should start working in 21
minutes we had so we wanted to give you
guys a chance to kind of blog and tweet
about this before anybody else so that's
why we held it back so yeah we made
having good documentation and samples a
priority from the beginning of this
project since you know providing good
guidance is really one of the major
goals so you're going to find in-depth
documentation that's written from the
perspective of an app developer you're
going to find really needy sample apps
that show how to build a real app and
just as an example of how much work went
into this we have a github browser
sample app that probably has better test
coverage than many real-world apps
written by that guy and and of course
we've had the guide to a parka texture
which internally we call the opinionated
guide for awhile and we think that label
still applies but even if you're not
planning to use our recommended
architecture we think people should
check out the guide it has principles
that we think apply to all apps on
Android and you're probably asking
yourself do I not you know what's the
impact of this going to be on me am I
going to have to kind of like change the
way that I'm doing everything you know
if you're starting a new project or if
you have an existing app that you want
to improve the core architecture then
yeah you know we recommend taking a look
at this stuff it's still preview we
won't be hitting 1.0 for a few months
but you know we think it's it's
definitely ready for you guys to check
out and use in projects but if you're
happy with what you have you don't need
to rewrite your app so in the spirit of
be together not the same we're not
dictating what everyone has to use if
you're happy with your app architecture
you can keep it if you're happy with
your existing or EMM you don't have to
use room
architecture components are designed to
work well together but they do work
perfectly fine standalone and mixing and
matching applies not only to
Architecture components but also
third-party libraries so waiting for
sled to come up so yeah so you can kind
of use what you have and to start to
integrate architecture components where
they make sense so for example if you're
happy with our X Java but you really
like the life cycle aware components
stuff they eat just showed so you have
these kind of like self-sufficient
components you can use live data
together with rx Java so you can get all
the power of rx Java operators and now
it's life cycle safe so kind of the best
of both worlds and we've got additional
integrations to come we're definitely
looking at a lot of stuff internally
that would be nice if it were kind of
like self-sufficient and life cycle
aware and if you're a library developer
we really recommend checking out life
cycles and life cycle observer because
we think there is a really bright future
and a lot of potential in making
libraries and components that are life
cycle aware by default but before you go
do that we have a lot more for you at
i/o this year we have two more talks one
on life cycles it's even more in depth
than what we just showed tomorrow
morning we have another one on room and
persistence and going a little bit
beyond room starting at 12:30 tomorrow
and we'll be well we'll have people who
are kind of well versed in architecture
components in the sandbox for all i/o
and we also have code labs which were
which we're pretty happy with and
there's more to come so we think we've
just scratched the surface of ways that
we can improve the experience of using
Android frameworks and we're looking to
apply applying this approach in other
areas as well so some things already in
the works and we're also interested in
hearing from you on
kind of what else you'd like to see so
come by talk to us you know tell us what
you like what you don't and stay tuned
because we're really excited about the
future of Android development thank
[Applause]
[Music]